over now to patrick coburn he's a
columnist and independent at the
independent newspaper and author of
several books including the rise of
islamic state joins me now from cork in
ireland good to have you with us mr
cobin on the programme how credible is
it that isil are alive and well in
afghanistan and where is this
intelligence coming from
well they're certainly present there
the un says they have 1500 to
200
fighters there
um where the information information is
coming from probably from an informant
or intercepted
communications but this is a very
chaotic situation
so having definitive information like
this is almost impossible at the moment
is it just a convenient you might say
a moment to have like a bogeyman
available for both the taliban and for
nato and nato allies to say you know
there is this other dark force at work
to sort of distract you might say or
frighten the locals
at their own inadequacies of trying to
handle what's going on inside and
outside of the airport
that's an interesting point
um
one of the
things that the u.s demanded from the
taliban during the negotiations uh in
doha was that the
taliban shouldn't
have an open door for al qaeda or
al-qaeda type organizations like isil
um
which uh they agreed to
but um
first of all in the present situation
it might not be easy for them to do
anything about it when you uh at the
airport i mean all you need is a truck
with explosives on board and uh
difficult to stop
but there is one important point about
the taliban that i think people miss out
on which is before 2001 the taliban
needed al qaeda assam bin laden provided
money
provided
fanatical fighters for the front line
and of course they assassinated with two
suicide bombers the leader of the
northern alliance uh uh
um
so
this was um
the the taliban no longer need an
alliance with al qaeda and it's much in
their interest indeed that they
shouldn't have one
whether we talk about post uh 2001 or a
pre-2000 or post 2001 just for our
international viewers in terms of the
way that isil is made up i mean you know
we mustn't perhaps think of it as a
legitimate force an army that is
controlled by central command
many
experts i've spoken to in the last
couple of days have talked about isil
being very isolated right now and it
could be just the odd um suicide bomber
here or there is that the sort of isil
we're looking at
it sort of is but the odd suicide bomber
here and there can do an awful lot of
damage
you know particularly against soft
targets it appears to have been them
that attacked this
shia hazara school in kabul
earlier in the year and killed 85 school
children uh there was an attack on a
hospital you know these things aren't
difficult to do
with a couple of suicide bombers uh who
don't have any expertise other than to
blow themselves up i mean it's been
quiet so far but the taliban did release
many isil operatives inadvertently in
those prison uh prison releases um do
you think the taliban are going to have
to deal with isil in some shape or form
sooner rather than later
i think they will after one they've won
a great victory and they'll want to
assert their power over all of
afghanistan
they'll also want uh acceptance by uh
other countries you know for reasons
we've just been hearing about now they
need aid they need food and so forth
so it's in their interest to say we are
the barrier against isis you may not
like us but there's a that could be
worse to come so it's much in their
interest to do that at the same time
they
the taliban and isil and al-qaeda do
appeal to the same constituency at
various uh points they're
interchangeable some of the isil many of
the isil leaders are full and former
taliban so you two have these two
different processes uh an impulse for
the taliban to crack down which is a
very strong but at the same time isil
isn't so far different
uh from uh their own organization
something else really to ponder on
because
they've been sworn enemies so they say
for many years fighting you might say a
puppet government in kabul supported by
the west so how does the current
situation then change the way isil if
they are well organized and funded from
acting successfully in a taliban
controlled afghanistan you know will
they see the taliban now as much as the
enemy
as the west because they have a
different sort of islamic ideology
well i saw you know as we saw in iraq
and syria tends to think of practically
everybody as an enemy apart from itself
and he's prepared perfectly prepared to
kill them and we have countless examples
of that so this might well be so i mean
they've already said this isn't uh the
taliban victory isn't uh
as pure as to the taliban claim so i
think they will uh contest it
um
but uh there's also a good reason why
the taliban should try to suppress them
or at least present themselves as the
barrier against isil
and use that as leverage with foreign
states in order to get recognition to
get aid and so forth we should see what
happens in the coming days for the
moment patrick coben thanks so much for
joining us from cork in ireland thank
you